when you run applications in production
you need to monitor the infrastructure
they run on you also need to measure the
golden signals of application health
like error rates and latency today i'm
going to show you how to instrument your
service to expose application specific
telemetry with prometheus and how to
configure google's managed prometheus
service to ingest those metrics i'm yuri
an sre at google welcome back to
engineering for reliability with google
cloud
[Music]
last time we started using google's
managed service for prometheus by
replacing the prometheus image with
google's forked image that enabled
ingesting prometheus metrics into the
managed backend and clearing them using
promptql
those metrics were then also available
in cloud monitoring and you can start
using them charts dashboards and alerts
that was enough to start collecting
infrastructure metrics from our cluster
today we're going to go two steps
further i'm going to show you how to
instrument your service to expose
telemetry and how to configure
prometheus to ingest those metrics we'll
do that by sending a managed prometheus
collection a zero management way to run
prometheus and the way to go if you're
new to prometheus or setting up a new
cluster alright let's get into it the
first step is to instrument our service
itself to expose a dedicated endpoint
that prometheus can use to scrape for
metrics
we covered this in our previous episode
on custom metrics but let's have a quick
look at an example in python we'll of
course link to the full sample in the
episode notes
[Music]
this is an example python flask app that
just has a basic homepage let's walk
through the code together first import
the necessary modules
then define the metrics you want to
capture in this example we're going to
track total requests failed requests and
a latency distribution
we can use a decorator to time how long
it takes to load a specific route
and we can increment the counters as
needed
finally we specify the endpoint where
prometheus metrics should be exposed
now we can see the data on the slash
metrics endpoint we're now ready to move
on to the second step and configure
prometheus to collect and ingest this
data
let's start by verifying that our
application is ready to be monitored by
prometheus
we can use port forwarding to confirm
that it's exposing prometheus metrics on
the slash magic endpoint
[Music]
in order to get our application
monitored by manage prometheus
collection we need to do two things
first we'll use this gcloud command to
install managed prometheus in our
cluster
note that you can do this using cube ctl
if your cluster is not running in gke
at this point we can confirm that
infrastructure collection is working by
querying metrics that the managed
prometheus collector is ingesting about
itself for example
[Music]
now we're ready to get our application
monitored by creating a new pod
monitoring resource
the selector specifies which pods to
monitor based on label down
and the endpoints specify where to
scrape for metrics
as we saw before our application is
exposing prometheus metrics on the slash
metrics endpoint on port 8080 which is
called metrics in the deployment
configuration
once that's applied let's run a query to
confirm that application metrics are
being adjusted
[Music]
and there we are
we can also query this metrics in
metrics explore simply by searching for
it like this
and that's how you can instrument your
application for prometheus monitoring
and have its metrics be collected and
ingested by the google managed service
for prometheus
thanks so much for watching today we'll
learn how to instrument your application
for prometheus monitoring and how to
configure google's managed service for
prometheus to collect those metrics
next time we'll have a look at how to
migrate an existing prometheus
deployment to the managed service for
prometheus and if you have any other
topics you'd like me to cover please
comment below
don't forget to like and subscribe to
never miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud see you
soon
[Music]
you